je vous emmène maintenant au danemark à
copenhague la capitale une région du
monde souvent cité évidemment pour sa
qualité de vie
le fameux modèle scandinave et bien
jean-sébastien cloutier
vous venez du passé une semaine ou
d'annappes aussi en suède il faut dire
mes impôts chaud mais nous ne rapporter
une série de reportages et vous fait des
comparaisons fort intéressante on va le
voir au cours des dix fed avec montréal
ouais voilà vous savez vous l'avez dit
on cite souvent en exemple en bon
exemple les pays scandinaves mais on a
l'impression qu'elle que soit le domaine
or si un domaine patrice qui est
d'actualité s'est initié à montréal ces
domaines du transport donc nous allons
nous aller passer quelques jours au
danemark et en suède pour voir ce qui se
passait là bas pas pour dénigrer
montréal mais pour tirer des conclusions
de leur expérience pour voir ce qu'on
pourrait peut-être apporter ici alors on
est revenu avec cinq histoires on
commence ce choix avec copenhague
capitale mondiale du vélo au cours des
prochaines semaines on vous parlera des
navettes fluviales à göteborg la
deuxième plus grande ville de suède
on vous parlera du péage urbain qui
existe autour du centre ville de
göteborg depuis deux ans on parlera de
l' architecture moderne qui est souvent
beaucoup plus spectaculaire qui si au
danemark et finalement du nouveau métro
de copenhague et son financement alors
où on a beaucoup de projets de transport
en commun ici à montréal donc début ce
choix copenhague capitale mondiale du
vélo montréal on n'a pas à rougir on
n'est pas si mal mais vous allez voir
que dans la capitale du danemark au
mérite ce titre voici donc une visite
guidée cycliste des livres
au creux d'une baie au nord est du
centre ville la petite sirène de
copenhague reçoit chaque jour la visite
de milliers de personnes elle est le
symbole par excellence de la ville mais
d'année en année un autre symbole à fait
sa place ici moins touristique certes
mais peut-être plus impressionnant
encore le vélo
ici c'est dans la culture tout le monde
a sa bicyclette
que l'on soit jeune ou plus vieux seul
ou en famille on l'utilisent pour aller
partout 45 % des résidants de la région
de copenhague vont à l'école ou au
travail en vélo peu taux qui monte à 63
% chez les 600 mille résidents de la
ville tous ces cyclistes profitent des
infrastructures parmi les meilleurs de
la planète
christine bourdin habite ici depuis 20
ans accompagnée de sa petite adèle elle
nous a fait une visite guidée du
copenhague cyclistes
christine a choisi la capitale du
danemark pour sa qualité de vie et le
vélo en fait partie c'est une ville
agréable à vivre qui est pas polluer
c'est une ville
verte où les gens sont beaucoup moins
stressé ou n'y a pas d'embouteillage
premières constatations il y à des voies
cyclables partout grand copenhague
on y compte 1000 km pistes séparées des
routes et exclusive au vélo en plus de
quelques centaines de kilomètres qui ont
été tracées aux abords des rues elle
semble tout dans un très bon état sans
nids-de-poule et bien signalisés parmi
ces pistes celle du nord brogues colonne
vertébrale nord-sud de la ville cyclable
42 mille vélos peuvent passer chaque
jour compteur à l'appui l'heure de
pointe ici est impressionnante
c'est la rue la plus empruntée par les
cyclistes de tous copenhague et de toute
l'europe de l'ouest d'ailleurs quelques
découvertes intéressantes nous attendent
ensuite voici par exemple repose pieds
installé à côté d'une intersection où
les voitures sont nombreuses
copenhague en compte quelques-uns tu
reposes de ton pied quand le feu est
rouge et ça a comme comme conséquence le
fait que moins de cyclistes grill feu
rouge
parce que tu as beaucoup plus envie de
s'arrêter puis de faire une petite pause
quelques kilomètres plus loin
ce nouveau pont courbe est inauguré en
2014 pour relier le centre ville
un tout nouveau quartier du sud de
copenhague
déjà considéré comme une icône de la
ville ont la bêtise et de snake le
serpent en raison de sa forme courbée
élégante qui passe par dessus la mer et
ça ça nous a vraiment facilité la vie un
pont aérien qui n'est que cyclables
le snec est une des fiertés du vice
maire de copenhague responsable des
dossiers transports à la ville depuis
dix ans nous dépensons en moyenne 15
millions de dollars canadiens par année
pour nos infrastructures cyclistes dit
morten kabel et il ajoute qu ici quand
on planifie les déplacements urbains on
pense évidemment aux transports
écologiques personnage important du vélo
à copenhague
mikael colville andersen et le patron de
copenhague ena
des zain une entreprise conseil pour les
villes qui souhaitent développer leurs
réseaux cycliste chaque deux ans lui et
ses collègues publie l'index copenhague
et nice des meilleures villes vélo de la
planète en 2015
copenhague s'est classée première ici
tous les élus mais monsieur plus à
droite disent oui aux dépenses pour la
bicyclette
la raison est simple
regardez toutes les études qu'on a ici
sur les avantages du vélo dit il à court
terme on économise des coûts en santé ou
parce qu'il y a moins de retard au
travail peut nouveaux kilomètres de
voies réservées serait remboursé à la
société en cinq ans on poursuit la
visite avec christine direction le métro
dont chaque station à d'ailleurs son
ascenseur juste au dessus des rames
voici une cave à vélo les copenhague war
kids et pose souvent les leurs parce que
les vélos sont interdits dans le métro à
l'heure de pointe
par exemple mon mari il a 3 3 principaux
employeurs donc il a un vélo poilley de
la maison à la station de métro
ensuite il le laisse à la cave à vélo il
reprend métro et prend son deuxième vélo
le transport en commun est adapté aux
cyclistes dans les trains de banlieue
plusieurs sièges une fois relevé dévoile
des supports à vélos de retour à
l'extérieur
un coup d'oeil sur cette immense
stationnement assez grand pour
accueillir des milliers de bicyclettes
les stationnements de voitures par
contre sont difficiles à trouver
d'ailleurs au danemark l'achat d'une
voiture est taxé à 180 pour cent ont dit
qu'à copenhague selon 22 % de ménages
possèdent une voix
et que seulement 10% des copenhague war
on utilise une chaque jour la
cohabitation vélo autour se fait bien il
n'y aurait en moyenne chaque année qu'un
seul accident mortel impliquant un
cycliste
on est quand même mon nom il sait qu est
ce qu un univers avec le vélo il ya peu
de changements ou fait en ont fait du
vélo jusque
- 5 - 10 on s'habille en famille tout
flou l'hiver a beau être moins rude car
montréal 3 copenhague oit sur quatre
roues la vélo 12 mois par année
ici les pistes cyclables sont sales et
déneiger avant les routes
c'est une question priorité dit michael
cohl wilander chine pour que quelqu'un
choisissent le vélo donnez lui des
infrastructures fiables
tellement de choses à montrer à
copenhague
adele a fini par s'endormir le temps de
passer devant quelques-uns des 600
magasins de vélo de la ville et nous
avons dit au revoir à christine puis au
détour d'une autre piste cyclable cette
nouvelle découverte une série de
lumières vertes qui s'allument pour
indiquer aux cyclistes qui l'ont la
bonne vitesse pour se synchroniser avec
le feu vert
dire que copenhague trouve qu'elle en a
encore beaucoup à faire
ces cyclistes et synchroniser les
cyclistes avec les feux verts on est à
des années lumières de forfait parce que
les voitures ici à montréal bon comment
on peut comparer les deux villes pas ces
deux planètes disons leur oui on a quand
même sorti quelques statistiques
intéressantes des chiffres qu'on veut
mettre en perspective d'abord prévoir un
tableau copenhague est une ville
beaucoup plus petite que montréal tant
en termes de superficie qu en terme de
population 570 mille habitants environ à
copenhague à peu près trois fois plus à
montréal 1 745 millions cela étant dit
les pistes cyclables on le voyait dans
le reportage dans le grand copenhague
est à peu près 1200 km de pistes
cyclables donc 1000 km de pistes
réservées aux vélos
à montréal c'est quand même pas si mal
650 km la piste la plus utilisée
à copenhague on disait 42 mille vélos et
circulent chaque jour ici à montréal
c'est la piste sur brébeuf où je me
trouve ce soir un peu plus derrière
moins jusqu'à 8500 vélo par jour maximum
les déplacements quotidiens là c'est là
que ça fait mal pour montréal on le
disait 63%
mais copenhague oies se déplace en vélo
pour aller travailler ou à la l'école à
montréal 3,2 pour cent seulement cela
dit dans certains quartiers centraux
comme le plateau mont royal sait
beaucoup plus sur le plateau plus de 10%
ce sont de vieux chiffons s'attend à ce
que les prochains chiffres soient plus
élevés mais finalement les
investissements
copenhague un vélo devant moi à
copenhague 15 millions par année en
infrastructures cyclistes depuis 10 ans
à montréal depuis 2009 c'est à peu près
10 millions par année on l'a vu dans
votre reportage de sébastien lepape le
gourou du vélo et sur l'organisme qui a
placé copenhague en première position a
fait baisser à retrogadé montréal
pourquoi 20e montréal montréal est et 8e
en 2011 dans le copenhague analyse index
en 2013 14e et la 20e même que
minneapolis en amérique du nord est
passé en dix huitième
écoutez un mikael colville andersen et
canado danois en fait il a grandi en
alberta y connaît bien
montréal il est venu souvent et koné
vielleux ferrandez également mais dit
que oui montréal a toujours bien fait a
été pionnière
sauf qu'on avance trop tranquillement et
qu'il ya d'autres villes qui nous ont
dépassés
je laisse l'écouté aurait pu lui parler
d'autres problèmes du plateau mais ça
c'est une autre histoire
vous avez rencontré la présidente de
vélo québec suzanne lareau savoir ce
qu'elle pense de tout ça
ouais connais bien copenhague n'est pas
d'accord que monsieur colville andersen
qui dit qu'un manque de volonté
politique et digg monsieur coderre es
salam en font beaucoup mais que le
problème à montréal c'est dans la
machine c'est trop long on avait promis
50 km de pistes cyclables cette année on
aura 30 35 a dit que le problème est
dans la machine cela dit effectivement
montréal pourrait à court terme
s'inspirer de bonnes idées à copenhague
voici deux solutions selon elle selon
elle la première chose qui me vient en
tête et au torse
ce autoroutes pour cyclistes et
d'alphonse et prendre des gens qui sont
en banlieue qui se déplace vers le
centre et qu'ils ont dans le fond envie
se déplacer plus rapidement que
d'arrêter à chaque intersection donc on
construit des pistes où les gens roulent
à une vitesse de 20 km/heure une moyenne
puis à peu près pas de lumière où quand
il ya des lumières c'est qu'elle tombe
toujours ouverte si vous roulez à 20 km
à apprécier des installations
spécifiques pour les cycles et on a vu
ce pont là le soutenait qui est
extraordinaire que j'ai peur que j'ai vu
en photo uniquement
alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'aurait pas
nous des des installations traite des
êtres particulière dédiée au cyclisme on
en a très peu à montréal et ça c'est
quelque chose qui frappe l'oeil
alors voilà en terminant vous avez
sûrement vu dans le reportage qui avait
pas beaucoup de gens qui avaient des
casques de vélo à copenhague ce n'est
pas obligatoire la bosse aller en suède
cela dit très peu d'accidents la
discipline des anneaux des danois et la
qualité des infrastructures cyclistes
l'expliquent entre autres pour dire
quand même jean sébastien pas de coca
beaucoup moins une cote à copenhague par
rapport à montréal - des chasses une
évidence et c'est un choix de société
vous avez dit dans votre reportage 180 %
de taxes quand on achète une voiture
parce que les québécois es mons
accepterait ça ouais ça veut dire qu'une
voiture de 20000 vous la paix le rhdp y
aurait environ 56 milles voilà je sais
pas c'est fort intéressant merci au
revoir